j'ai été maladroit ouais j'ai vous tu
sais j'ai
jugé dick connerie en fait que je ne
pensais pas mal d'ailleurs mais lui par
contre il a mal pris connerie c'était
sur ses filles oui oui j'ai dû caudry
mais je pensais pas être méchant du tout
du tout du tout les ans j'étais étonné
qu'ils réagissent aussi
aussi c'est que sa gym à google et un
jour je le rencontre j'écoute fréquents
même quand je parle du jeu back par les
milices est que ça tombe bien they came
goûter bien avancé mais parler tu as dit
que tu m'as jus du jeu que j'avais fait
une connerie je le regrettais que je
n'avais pas une minute envie de 2,2
comment dire de faire de la peine qui
que ce soit ou de maîtrise et de la
profitation sur scène les mots près
c'est de la pensée tu tues tu vas tu te
lances dilapidant ce que l'immersion
temps de faire une connerie tu te
rattrape comme tu peux mais je suis mal
rattraper faudra-t-il a connu à temps
il a dit c'est qu'on a dit entouré de
mec vachement sympa dans notre métier a
donc là qu'ils ont mis la haine
et
la bande en phase 1 a rajouté un paquet
et on dirait sardou
huawei donc c est s est définie après ce
témoin on ne voit plus trop à la télé
michel tu aimes bien faire de la télé ou
pas non
si dieu vient faire de la télé quand
j'ai quelque chose à
véritablement faire tu vois une annonce
à faire 1 comment dire faire un show par
exemple atteint si
les [ __ ] tu as tu veux tu vas être
le tirage avec les [ __ ] j'ai fait et
j'ai fait là il fait beau ouais j'ai
fait le plus beau le niveau pour
améliorer effet promis on ya 35 sur
scène il n'y avait pas tout ce barnum
n'avait que avec tout le monde enfin on
était 5 et tout le monde chantait
lorelei avait duo il y avait tout tu
voyais avait il y avait toute la famille
il y avait une ambiance formidable et
dans la salle c'était formidable c'était
le premier des restos du coeur
maintenant je trouve ça un peu barnum
ont fait changer des footballeurs ont
fait chanter des
gémeaux du tu vois c'est plus la même
chose c'est un truc de musique les
restos du coeur ils t'ont demandait de
revenir ou pas oui mais je pouvais pas
parce que j'étais en tournée chez secor
chose et le théâtre j'ai jamais refusé
de le faire mais mais si tu veux je
trouve ça moins sympathique que cette
époque la voie où il ya eu un gag
épouvantable avec eddy mitchell parce
que
comment elle s'appelle
samson véronique sanson décale sur le
temps un mois et demi lui c'est le temps
un avis au fond du temps à l'hôtel des
cales ce qui fait qu il est parti au
troisième temps lieu de partir au
premier et sa bande est parti en couille
il a chanté en anglais lavabo
c'était l'endroit on disait aux gens
donner parce que c'est important que
vous donniez c'est du pognon qui va
aller donner à manger aux gens qui n'en
n'ont pas et on est pris une crise
d'origine et on est partis pleuré sous
là sous la batterie donc ça a été foutu
non les gens de l'ombre et blu ray ban
michel était un des personnages les plus
aimés de france et pourtant on t'accuse
et de toute loi c'est un truc de fou et
apologie de la colonisation avec le de
la chanson le temps des colonies alors
que c'était lentilles ouais cd je me
foutait de la gueule des anciens avec
être une femme ont accusé de misogynie
studio un internaute accusé de tous que
tu dis ah ça aux gens qui disent être
une femme assez passé s'est passé ça le
rire du sergent avait accusé
d'homophobie oui par exemple un
moment une des polémiques les plus
connus de ta carrière c est ta chanson
je suis pour pour la peine de mort
est là aussi voilà
c'est tu sais ça c'est vrai que ça a été
une polémique aussi ouais c'était une
époque tu sais 70 80 90 c'était le
comment dirais-je
très manichéen
j'étais le seul chanteur qui s'affirmait
de droite ouais mais d'une droite
gaulliste tu vois je suis pas un fou
furieux
et
tous les autres tv de gauche alors
évidemment j'en ai pris plein les yeux
et d'un autre côté ça m'a beaucoup servi
que j'en ai pris tellement plein la
gueule quand je dis j'ai pas des choses
graves j'ai parlé maintenant j'ai
l'impression que tu t'en [ __ ] ta maman
est partie de là comme celle de sa mère